cette condamnation va vous faire
réfléchir à deux fois avant de vous
moquer de la calvitie de vos amis la
prochaine fois
en effet la justice britannique vient de
condamner un homme pour avoir injurié
son salarié de côte de chauffe quand %
des salariés déclarent avoir déjà été
victimes d'au moins un comportement
hostile au travail une condamnation pour
harcèlement sexuel
étonnant pourtant le tribunal est formel
c'est un juré sexistes et pourrait être
comparable à l'évocation de la taille de
la poitrine d'une jeune femme
et ses shows à ce monde
employés licenciés va donc recevoir une
belle indemnité après son licenciement
et gare à celui qui osera dire que cet
argent lui servira à faire des implants
il est important de dire que les trois
juges qui ont donc jugé cette affaire
étaient eux mêmes
le comprendre ce qui n'est pas
nécessairement de neutralité sur leur
ligne mais je trouve que c'est une
insulte en fait aux victimes
d'agressions sexuelles suis désolé
une condamnation même internationale
enfin j'veux pas si ça existe je suis
pas encore calées là dedans mais
il
faut les punir parce que ça ça ça voilà
ces impacts tout le monde et franchement
c'est honteux je trouve ça on devient
fou dans médi c'est que c'est porter
atteinte à la dignité c'est ça qu'ils
ont trouvée non ils ont quand même ça à
la poitrine d'une heure s'est tenue
entre états vous savez pourquoi oui les
et pardon thyroïde ceci dit moi je
trouve que moi je suis très sensible si
on critique sur mes cheveux que
parce que c'est du faux
vous êtes d'un vieux bernard
j'ai touché les cheveux j'ai pas touché
autre chose mais c'est vrai que c'est
vrai que je suis un homme c'est c'est
très irritant quand on reçoit des
oui
vous savez qu'il est généralement ou
perd ses cheveux c'est quand on a un
excès de testostérone invoquons discours
viril c'est des vrais les vrais bons
viril c'est en tout cas pas ses cheveux
ce qui est mon cas c'est que
aujourd'hui dans l'histoire en tout cas
il ya vraiment une vraie histoire pour
le coup parce que je conseille bien que
jules césar poumon prennent et jules
césar bah oui
c'était pour cacher sa calvitie et on
les bicornes pourquoi calvitie naissante
alain 14 h c'est lui qui lance la mode
des péris coudray tous ces gens-là to c
grand chef de l'état avait un problème
avec la calvitie ça avait changé les
modes à voilà voilà on sait qu'il est
propre et carey fait du dégât merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]